ah
[Música]
parís parece presa de una cebra de
alegría que no cesa desde el anuncio de
la llegada del delantero argentino en
cara gesto de la capital el nombre de
leonel messi está absolutamente en todos
los labios pero aquí en el partido los
principios el estadio del parís alarma
donde la energía es más intensa los
seguidores que llevan tres días
esperando son miles hombres mujeres
jóvenes y mayores están allí cantando y
honor del psg y de lo en el mes y donde
mes y que durante su primer obrera de
presa dicen que era feliz de estar en
parís y que quería ganar otra champions
league también dejó claro que no sabe
cuándo va a debutar y tiene que hacer
una temporada propia justo después el
presidente del club también destacó que
querían mbappe se queda en el equipo la
llegada en el pc es la esperanza para
llegar a dimensión en el pf en la
esperanza para el club y de ganar la
liga de estas canciones esta competición
europea que el psg lleva varios años
luchando por ganar
[Música]
barcelona- dijo adiós a leo messi y su
marcha tiene un gran impacto a todos los
niveles equipos y mejor a nivel
deportivo del fc barcelona pierde a su
hombre el récord el máximo goleador el
con más títulos y más victorias pero
también crea un gran impacto económico
tanto para el club que según cálculos
del sector podría dejar de ingresar
entre el 130 y 170 millones anuales como
también para la liga quien pierde a su
última super estrella y esto tiene
consecuencias por ejemplo cuando
cristiano ronaldo se fue a italia pues
en los partidos del real madrid
perdieron un 10% de espectadores y
finalmente el que más notamos aquí es el
impacto afectivo los aficionados están
entre tristes e indignados pero todos
dicen que no le tienen rencor a leo
messi y que podrá volver aquí porque
siempre llega a su casa
[Música]
en argentina no pasaron desapercibidas
las referencias al origen de leonel
messi en el despliegue comunicacional
que el parís saint germain hizo en la
presentación de su nuevo fichaje sobre
todo el tuit una imagen partida de un
lado un mes y de espalda frente a la
torre eiffel con la camiseta 30 de su
nuevo club tomando la mano de un mes y
niño que está del otro lado con la
camiseta número 10 de newll's old boys-
su equipo de la infancia frente al
monumento a la bandera de rosario un
icono de su ciudad natal hay además un
vínculo clave entre el rosario y la
capital francesa en esta historia el
director técnico del parís saint germain
mauricio pochetino también inició su
carrera en jules old boys y en la
conferencia de prensa de su presentación
en parís messi dijo que habló con
pochettino durante las negociaciones
para su fichaje y que el hecho de que
ambos sean argentino facilita mucho las
cosas para él mientras tanto como en
todo el mundo los comerciantes de
camisetas en argentina empiezan a
reemplazar la 10 del barcelona por la
número 30 del psg
[Música]